ah no you need to spend more time here
with a family where are you going be
back with what dinner be careful out
there no boy got a covered by I just
want to escape dad always wanted me to
travel the world someday
[Music]
Oh who's the Yeti on my roof hey boy or
girl yeah you're definitely a boy I
don't know where you came from he
escaped
I want my Yeti back is that your home No
you can tell
you make sure you get home we move to
your family ever since
okay stop it yourself this is you and
your parents no you have your mother's
eyes there are people looking for you
you can do magic
this is impossible I wish dad were here
to see this yeah ma Beijing is great
Oh thing is uh thanks fine you're eating
on
was this your dad smilin my dad used to
play for me every night like he was
telling me that no matter how hard the
journey kids never give up it's
beautiful
you did that II I did
when he sets her mind on something
nothing is impossible
[Music]
I've got blueberries in places where
boobies should never be
you